hey everyone peter brown with a gamespot
news update after years of rumors mafia
3 has officially been announced today's
official announcement of mafia three
comes after years of rumors and
speculation in March 2012 it was
reported that mafia two developer 2k
Czech was working on a third entry in
the series at the time the studio had
supposedly entered full-time development
on mafia 3 following a year of
pre-production work and image released
on Twitter teases the location and time
period for mafia three though 2k has yet
to confirm that information the
worldwide reveal will take place on
August fifth at eight a.m. eastern no
information was provided regarding
platforms but the games website reveals
the newly formed studio hangar 13 to be
the developer Hayden Blackman who worked
at lucasarts in the 1990s and 2000s is
leading the team at hangar 13 in a
statement 2k said mafia 3 is the next
installment in the popular series known
for immersing players into a world of
organized crime through rich narrative
storytelling in a beautifully crafted
game world featuring period-accurate
cars music and fashion mafia 2 came out
in 2010 and was an open world
action-adventure game that was met with
praise for his authentic setting more
details on mafia 3 will be revealed at
Gamescom next week and I will be there
to give you guys all the news but in the
meantime for other gaming news stay
tuned to gamespot com